poignet elle même elle donne l émission
est faite pour ça envie de lire de les
connaître et de prolonger ces rencontres
je vous dis merci je vous dis bravo
merci à vous tous
et puis à vous qui nous regardent et de
cyprès et souvent de si loin et qui nous
écrivaient de 2 partout et à accepter
les remerciements dalle marie moreau de
philippe lallemand le le réalisateur de
talent oriane gens courent si lille mais
velec ana markovic
je devrais juste toute cette équipe a
énormément de talent et fidélité je la
remercie
nous nous sentons d'ailleurs tous très
proches de vous merci à bientôt
à
il y à 70 ans l'appel du général de
gaulle à l'occasion des célébrations du
18-juin débat sur public sénat le regard
croisé d'un témoin de l'époque et de
ceux qui aujourd'hui se réclame de
l'héritage alors que reste-t-il du
gaullisme
le débat c'est à suivre sur public sénat
le débat ce soir à 23h sur public sénat
bonjour est ravie de vous retrouver dans
ce nouveau numéro de parlement hebdo en
compagnie d'emmanuel kessler bonjour
bonjour
que s'est il passé cette semaine dans
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
c'est ce que nous allons voir avec bien
sûr le maître mot de la semaine les
retraites le ministre du travail
présenté cette semaine la réforme tant
attendue
départ à 62 ans 41 ans et demi de
cotisations
les syndicats et l'opposition crie à
l'injustice sociale et promettent une
rentrée chaude lors de l'examen
parlementaire retraite toujours cette
fois celle des députés bernard accoyer
annonce la réduction de certains
avantages liés au régime dont ils
bénéficient quant au ministre ils ne
pourront plus cumuler leurs salaires
avec une retraite parlementaire message
la rigueur cette aussi pour les
politicards fait la moisson de la
semaine du canard enchaîné les 12000
euros de cigares de christian blanc le
permis de construire d'alain joyandet ou
encore le mondial cinq étoiles de rama
yade
chaque semaine l'hebdomadaire satirique
fait mouche sur les abus des membres du
gouvernement
la liberté de la presse ne s'use que si
l'on ne s'en sert pas certains doivent
trouver qu'on s'en sert trop il ya sûr
on y reviendra est notre invité de la
semaine david douillet bonjour jours
merci d'être avec nous un sportif en
politique etc sportif et vos restons le
reste quand même tout gentil simple à la
bombe
chacun connaît votre formidable carrière
de judoka le plus titré de l'histoire
double médaillé olympique quadruples
champions du monde
puis la transition sous la halle
protectrice on va dire de jacques et
bernadette chirac puisque vous avez
parrainer l'opération pièces jaunes et
la nouvelle vie bien sûr l'entrée dans
l'arène parlementaire avec votre
élection comme député sous la bannière
de l'ump c'est en automne dernier qui
vous vaut d'ailleurs une
standing-ovation à l'époque souvenez
sûrement bien sûr ça ne s'oublie pas de
vos nouveaux collègues lors de votre
première entrée dans l'hémicycle alors
comment avez vous vécu cette première
saison va dire pour reprendre un langage
un peu sportif à l'assemblée nationale
est ce que cette amende
c'est une courte saison déjà pour
commencer parce qu'il a fallu apprendre
dès l'arrivée le fonctionnement les
codes les us et coutumes qui fait quoi
comment pourquoi et puis et puis ensuite
il a fallu travailler mais je crois que
les choses sont fermées en fait en même
temps moi je me souviens de cette
première journée c'était assez assez
extraordinaire mais c'est intimidant
c'est exaltant c'est quoi ah c'est très
intimidant départ je me souviens de ma
première réflexion quand je suis entrée
dans l'hémicycle le plein c'est de me
dis je me suis senti au coeur de la
démocratie
voilà je me suis je si je suis là au
coeur de la démocratie
et voilà ça ça va ça bat ici on sent que
là-bas on sent que c'est sérieux il
d'histoire historique est ici parce
qu'on sent qu'il se passe beaucoup de
choses on est avec vous et cosignée déjà
des propositions de lois mais vous
n'avez pas encore la vôtre est ce que
vous attendez vous j'attends j'ai
attendu oui parce que on m'a proposé
d'être rapporteur d'une loi assez
rapidement c'est d'ailleurs très
gentiment
la proposition de martin hirsch à
l'époque que j'avais refusé parce que
c'était un peu tôt ce terme ans après
mon arrivée il faut le temps de
l'humidité d'apprendre et de savoir
comment ça fonctionne mais j'ai trois
propositions de loi en cours de route la
sur différents sujets à cela le problème
c'est que c'est ajouter beaucoup de
choses quand je suis arrivé le président
m'a donné une mission tout de suite qui
va être rendu
peut-être la semaine prochaine
d'ailleurs sur les grands événements
sportifs et là la façon dont allah
accueillir les plus grands événements
sportifs en français et la structuration
de l'immobilisme sportif aussi donc ça
me demandez pas mal de travail
même si on a fini cette mission il ya
déjà plus de deux mois
il ya beaucoup de travail en
circonscription aussi enfin bref ya un
travail parlementaire avec des ambitions
gouvernementales déjà
oui mais ça c'est de l'ordre de la
rumeur je me suis jamais exprimé là
dessus
moi je considère que je vois je me suis
investi en politique parce que j'avais
réussi ma première vie aimait ma
première vie celle dont vous avez parlé
c c'est la vie où vous avez envie
d'assouvir vos rêves voilà bon je les
fais j'ai eu la chance de le faire
il se trouve que la canada sportif ça se
fait plutôt jeune et donc ça vous laisse
du temps après pour faire beaucoup de
choses j'ai fait dix ans entre il ya eu
dix ans de intermédiaire entre un mac
car le sportif et et celle d'aujourd'hui
où j'ai où j'ai appris la vie j'ai
compris la vie donc dans beaucoup de
domaines domaine de l'entreprise et
c'est ce qui m'a permet aujourd'hui
d'être sûr de mon choix qui est celui de
servir l'intérêt général
voilà je ne suis pas ici pour mon ego il
est déjà comblé
en revanche ce plaisir de servir
l'intérêt général que ce soit ici en
circonscription ou ailleurs ne me donne
pas la volonté d'être ministre a trouvé
mon but ultime est de rendre un peu ce
que je pense avoir reçu de la nation de
l'état et de ma vie quoi bon alors on va
en venir justement à la politique et à
la manière dont vous l'abordez
aujourd'hui quand même un mot sur ce
mondial de football qui se passe au plus
mal pour
français la presse très sévère après le
deuxième match complètement raté de
l'équipe de france le meilleur jeu de
mots c'est celui du progrès on va le
voir l'appel la pelle du 17 juin les
bleus au fond du gouffre qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette situation
calamiteuse du foot national car cette
coupe du monde on avait eu des signes
avant coureurs déjà
moi ce qui me gêne c'est que malgré les
signes avant-coureurs les décisions
n'ait pas été prise pour essayer de
rectifier un petit peu le tir sans
genoux non plus parce que je considère
j'ai une analyse peut-être qui n'a pas
été dit encore qu'elle a pour le coup il
est très directement mon expérience je
trouve que dans une équipe là je vais
tâcher technique dans une équipe et dans
ce sport là où il ya une énorme pression
vous êtes une coupe du monde de foot aux
jeux olympiques
hamon et c'est tellement important que
vous avez tendance à voir plier sur vous
même vous mettre sous une bulle voilà et
donc l'encadrement qui est autour de
vous là pour le coup revêt une
importance essentielle considérable or
lorsque les joueurs ou les athlètes où
l'équipe n'a pas une grande affinité une
grande confiance ou un grand respect
vis-à-vis de son encadrement
l'homme de l'âme de l'équipe qui doit
exister n'est pas là est ce que j'ai vu
hier soir c'est ça excusez le
sélectionneur raymond domenech soyons
clair qu'il ya eu une vraie dans une
équipe il n'y a pas que le sélectionneur
ya tout l'encadrement may à lui via il
ya tout tout l'encadrement dont il fait
partie donc forcément lui mais tous les
gens qui sont autour mais y compris les
gens la fédération et c'est une alchimie
très dur
si on met plus en plus si vous la cie
vous là si vous n'avez pas ça et j'ai
pas vu ça hier soir ni lors du premier
match ça ne peut pas fonctionner serre
que les gens ont besoin à un moment
donné que les gens les athlètes ont
besoin moment donné comme vous êtes dans
cette bulle
ils ont envie de rendre à quelqu'un et
comme vous êtes menacés de but vous
rendez pas compte que c'est la nation
qui est derrière vous vous votre image
la plus proche c'est l'encadrement donc
si vous n'avez pas envie de faire
plaisir à votre encadrement c'est
compliqué ça va être compliqué c'est ce
qui se passe avec maradona et son équipe
regardez bien les images les joueurs on
envie de faire plaisir à leur coach à
l'encadrement est alors que l'ambiance
aussi peut-être
il embrasse ils viennent le voir il
discute avec eux enfin bref ya une vraie
communion ya une âme donc quand même
très franchement domenech n'a pas joué
correctement son rôle de sélectionneur
et c'est pas simple c'est pas simple
mais oui parce que c'est une équipe qui
est très hétérogène à vous faites comme
un peu là dit ami moi aussi aimé jacquet
il n'a pas su faire naître cette cette
âme qui existait en 98 grâce à aimé
jacquet le chef le cantonnier ces thèmes
et les joueurs respectent aimé jacquet
c'est un marché en 2006 je suis désolé
de le dire mais le chef le dieu de
l'équipe c'était inédit zidane et
l'équipe cette auto géré aujourd'hui
avec la crise y'a personne ayant nick
noah qui parle de joueurs trop payés qui
parle d'enfants gaieté donc que
contrairement contraire à l'esprit
sportif au vous souscrivez à ce qu'il
avait dit non l'argent n'a rien à voir
là dedans savez
c'est là tout le tool toute l'importance
d'avoir une âme c'est de faire prendre
conscience de l'enjeu de l'importance
des choses et de donner envie d'aller
jusqu'au bout rama yade elle n'avait pas
non plus à ce que laurent 81,18 les
joueurs étaient aussi bien payé je veux
dire c'est ils ont toujours été très
bien payé les footballeurs en 2006
lorsqu'ils sont au final aussi donc ça
n'a ce n'est pas le critère qui fait
revenir
elle avait raison rama yade de dénoncer
l'hébergement finalement on l'a beaucoup
critiquée des bleus je peux entrer dans
cette polémique parce que c'est pas mon
rôle
en revanche vous savez quand on est
athlète qu'on soit logé dans un 4 3 1 2
ou alors dans un hôtel très cheap vous
êtes tellement captivé normalement par
l'enjeu que peu importe là où vous êtes
normalement vous êtes sens très
concentrés sur le sujet allez on va en
venir à la politique maintenant on va
sauter sur la journée de lundi pour
aller directement à mardi avec des
députés qui se supprime eux mêmes
certains de leurs privilèges
en matière de retraites c'est une
application de la séparation des
pouvoirs ce sont les parlementaires eux
mêmes qui fixe leurs régimes de retraite
en ce mardi le président de l'assemblée
bernard accoyer annonce la suppression
de la double cotisation des députés
système qui leur permet de cotiser deux
fois moins longtemps et dans la même
journée les ministres concernés sont
priés de renoncer à leur retraite
parlementaire tant qu'ils sont au
gouvernement
le message est clair les politiques eux
aussi doivent faire des efforts
explications avec kamal abu reim
aujourd'hui quand un salarié doit
travailler 40 ans pour une retraite à
taux plein un député n'a besoin que de
c'est la conséquence d'une cotisation
deux fois plus élevé que le régime
normal sauf qu'avec la réforme des
retraite et l'allongement du temps de
travail
ce principe de double cotisation passe
mal des avantages que le président de
l'assemblée promet de revoir l titre
personnel je pense qu'il s'agit d'argent
public qu'aujourd'hui la situation des
finances de tous les grands pays comme
la situation des finances de la france
fonctionne lorsque l'état dépense un
euro il en emprunte plus de 50 centimes
et dans ces conditions le cumul
peut-être peut-être évalué en
particulier en s'inspirant de ce qui
existe sur le cumul des indemnités de
fonction pour les élus que le premier
ministre a été clair il écrit rare pour
leur interdire le cumul emploi retraite
parlementaire
avec la réforme constitutionnelle un
ministre pourrait revenir
automatiquement au parlement revenir
alors qu'il a déjà liquidé sa retraite
au gouvernement ils sont dix
ministres ou secrétaires d'état être
concernés les autres soutiennent le tour
de vis de françois fillon
c'est une activité pleine et entière
comme sept jours sur sept autres
ministres et je me senti que je me
sentais pas comme un retraité dansant
faut un bon donc jamais aucune raison de
toucher ma retraite voilà je touche pas
le moment venu
pour l'opposition il s'agit d'un juste
retour à la normale gouvernement se voit
dans l'obligation d'appliquer à ses
propres ministres
une mesure on va dire de justice et de
rigueur qu'il voulait appliquer à tous
les français deux objectifs pour le
gouvernement faire des économies et
surtout montrer l'exemple avant une
réforme des retraites très contestée par
l'opposition
alors david douillet est il normal de
réformer le régime de retraite des
députés ou alors vous pensez comme
certains cela compense la précarité de
la fonction non c'est l'argent volé il
ya une partie d'argent public dans la
retraite des députés au chant fou c'est
normal voilà d'ailleurs on en revient
sur un espèce de chute de sujets qui est
assez c'est intéressant je pense que
pour faire ce pour fait exercer cette
activité
c'est essentiel d'avoir fait autre chose
dans la vie est de pouvoir faire autre
chose après voilà donc j'en viens à dire
aussi que moi j'aimerais voir un peu
plus dans l'hémicycle beaucoup plus de
gens issus de la société civile et
notamment du monde de l'entreprise et du
privé au sens large avec cette
possibilité de faire ce vrai choix celui
j'ai fait par exemple de prendre une
tranche de 10 ans 15 ans dans sa vie peu
importe où l'on décide de travailler
pour pour la nation qu'il avait changé
vos activités prévues pour la télévision
ou la marque david douillet nid lors des
grands des vêtements vous avez quand
même une mission pour pour l'elysée pour
nicolas sarkozy vous en parliez tout à
l'heure
est il possible soir si vous avez été
rémunérés pour leur jeu pour cette
mission s'arrêtait jamais une
vous êtes pour la transparence totale
s'était valérie pécresse qui proposait
sa couronne complètement public les
rémunérations des démissions donner aux
notamment par le maintien
je veux vous dire oui assez facilement
puisqu'il est moi je n'avais pas j'ai eu
deux collaborateurs issus l'inspecteur
issue général et sport et un inspecteur
des finances voilà qui m'ont aidé eux
qui nous ont aidés parce que j'ai
constitué une équipe de 12 personnes en
fait qui ont travaillé bénévolement tous
sont tous sur sur la mission et voilà
justin petit jeu soit par curiosité la
retraite d'un sportif parce que là on
parle de 67 ans pour avoir une retraite
à taux plein j'imagine que le régime est
différent pour le régime off
il n'y a pas de régime pour les retraits
des sportifs c'est un grand problème
c'est très bien vous en parler
aujourd'hui c'est un sportif n'a pas
démarré le compteur de la retraite en
étant salarié dans une entreprise ou en
déclarant ses revenus liés à ses
activités en tant que professionnel donc
je vous parle de environ à les 60 à 70%
des athlètes parce que vous savez on
focalise toujours sur le foot le tennis
le golf les sports automobiles on gagne
beaucoup d'argent on n'a pas besoin de
se préoccuper de sa retraite mais je
peux vous dire que 90 95 % des athlètes
sega se vouvoyer aux jeux olympiques
pour certains vont démarrer le
le compteur des retraites à 30 ans et
plus et c'est le cas ça fait 20 ans
qu'on demande et qu'on essaie de trouver
des solutions auprès des différents
ministres et secrétaires d'état pour
trouver une solution pour que ces dix
ans de gens qui ont qui ont servi la
france en plus puissent avoir un moyen
de racheter ou ou de pouvoir combler ce
vide de dix ans vous imaginez des gens
qui ont mis à dos at his mandat
perchiste romain mesnil qui avait posé
nue pour nom mais ça veut dire qu'il ya
pas d'argent
finalement c'est au delà de quelques
sports stars et de quelques stars du
sport exactement les gens qui consacrent
toute leur vie et qu'ils ne se
retrouvent pas les moyens d'appliquer
alors pour les sportifs et concours les
actifs et les fédérations oui réellement
ça à faire non je plaisante pas
aujourd'hui on a des gens qui n'ont pas
la totalité de leurs trimestres et ils
ont plus de 70 ans ils sont évidemment
usé physiquement elle comprenait
pourquoi
et c'était un vrai problème à les
nouvelles variantes des apéros convoqué
via le site facebook elle qu'un
événement assez particulier des
militants qui se revendique laïque
d'autres proches de l'extrême droite il
se il voulait se retrouver et convié les
parisiens vendredi dans le quartier de
la goutte d'or à paris vendredi jour de
prière des musulmans et 18 juin une date
qui ne doit rien au hasard puisqu'il est
question de résistance à l'islamisme ce
projet d'apéro intitulé saucisson et
pinard a été finalement interdite par la
préfecture de police
il a soulevé la polémique si grave
malaise tout débute sur facebook lé mois
dernier une dénommée sylvie françois
invite les internautes à venir prendre
l'apéritif dans ce quartier parisien où
vit une forte population musulmane
au programme du rassemblement
dégustation de vins et de saucisson
alexandre père est membre du groupuscule
d'extrême droite bloc identitaire et le
co organisateur de l'événement
son objectif dénoncer dit il
l'islamisation de la france au
considérons que l'islam n'est pas
compatible avec notre identité avec nos
traditions avec notre culture sur des
possibles de se réapproprier ces
quartiers qui sont devenus des enclaves
musulmanes des zones de non france des
zones de non droit en quelques semaines
l'envi tation à l'apéritif reçoit près
de 6000 soutien sur le net
réaction immédiate des sceaux est
racisme l'association dénonce une
discrimination envers les musulmans qui
ne peuvent pas boire d'alcool ni manger
du porc il ya bien là une volonté de
stigmatiser les populations d'origine
arabo-musulmane
cela est évidemment quelque chose
extrêmement raciste qui renvoie à un
refus de l'évolution de la société
française et au refus de l'égalé dignité
qui est dû à l'ensemble des citoyens
quelle que soit leur origine ou leur
confession à l'origine de l'événement
le bloc identitaire en 2006 ce mouvement
anti islam avait lancé la mode des
soupes au cochon
quatre ans plus tard nouvelle campagne
avec un appui cette vidéo
une invitation lancée sur internet la
nouvelle vitrine des groupuscules
d'extrême droite pour les petites
structures avec peu de militants
internet représente une aubaine car il
n'avait pas c'est à dire d'abord il est
obligé de tracts et d'aller sur sur les
marchés ou dans les universités pour
faire adhérer ou ramener des gens
aujourd'hui avec internet et notamment
facebook
il arrive à toucher des gens qui
n'auraient jamais toucher autrement
après une semaine de polémique la
préfecture de paris a finalement
interdit l'opération pinard et saucisson
les organisateurs affirment qu'ils
maintiendront l'opération ailleurs dans
un lieu pour l'instant tenu secret
elle dit y ait ce genre de dérapages ou
d'initiatives entre guillemets qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire
moi ça m'inspire ça me chagrine parce
que c'est le résultat d'avoir laissé
faire en fait on a parlé de deux
communautés et c'est ça qui m'inquiète
pas bien faut pas que ce soit des
communautés c'est la france avec des
français point barre et il faut arrêter
le communautarisme
voilà ce phénomène concentrationnaire
qui amène des gens à prier dans la rue
c'est intolérable
évidemment pour des gens qui ne
comprennent pas qu'ils ne sont pas
habitués et qui connaissent pas
évidemment ça peut les choquer
forcément donc on a deux communautés qui
sont en train de monter en puissance
l'une contre l'autre alors que avec de
la communication du respect et puis
l'anticipation un peu et là je parlais
un peu d des pouvoirs publics qui
auraient pu anticiper un petit peu tout
ça au régler les problèmes de deux
mosquées qui sont pas encore construites
et c'est ce que je crois que c'est la
raison pour laquelle les gens sont
obligés de prier dans la rue eh bien on
n'en serait peut-être pas là mais hélas
ce qui se passe c'est qu'on est en train
de certains mettre de l'huile sur le feu
que ce soit les extrémistes
on va dire français et franchouillard et
les extrémistes musulmans
voilà moi la population qui m'intéresse
c'est ce qui va forcément les
extrémistes qui font la prière dans la
rue d'amiens
justement non mais bien sûr mais enfin
les extrêmes ne m'intéresse pas ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la partie du milieu
sont les gens comme vous et moi normaux
et comme beaucoup d'amis musulmans que
je peux avoir qui sont des gens
responsables et sensée et qui sont qu'à
tout à fait capables de vivre ensemble
il faut continuer ça voilà donc il faut
que les gens se parlent se comprennent
se respecte est las de cette manière on
peut vivre ensemble avec avec la
possibilité de pouvoir acheter du cochon
une bouteille de vin dans ce quartier
sans qui elle non plus des actions de
répression de l'autre côté
voilà c'est tout c'est comme ça quand ça
se parle et que ça communique ça va bien
elle va passer à la journée du mercredi
et cette fois c'est la réforme des
français que la réforme des retraites
alors c'est donc le jour de l'annoncé
tant attendue et rigueur expose son plan
de réforme des retraites l'âge légal de
départ repoussé à 62 ans une retraite à
taux plein automatique à 67 ans 41 ans
et demi de cotisations
un alignement à terme du régime des
fonctionnaires sur le privé et ce jour
là le ministre phare de la réforme a
multiplié les temps pour tenter de
convaincre un you and roll à la sortie
avait été préparé pendant plusieurs
semaines
à 8h30 ce matin début d'une journée
marathon pour eric woerth face à la
presse le ministre du travail abat ses
cartes
exercice périlleux vendre à l'opinion
publique la retraite à 62 ans
une véritable obligation morale et je
pèse mes mots
une réforme responsable donc mais aussi
une réforme évidemment j'ai évidemment
indispensable à la fois raisonnable et à
la fois efficaces équitables
elle est responsable elle est
raisonnable elle est juste donc cet item
ces candidats efficaces et justes dans
la bataille qui vient de s'engager
chaque mot chaque attitude seront
déterminants et le prochain rendez-vous
du ministre devenu vrp d'une réforme
impopulaire a une importance capitale en
fin de matinée audition devant la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'assemblée nationale
merci euros et pas deux jours et
première passe d'armes avec l'opposition
vous nous avez taxé d' irresponsable
vous nous avez taxé d' irréaliste vous
nous avez taxé de tous les noms
d'oiseaux qui pouvait vous passez par
l'esprit 10% pour le capital et les
hauts revenus
tout leur est payé par les salariés et
les retraités
donc je vois pas où est l'équité
pourquoi vous avez peur
pourquoi avez vous peur vous ne
raisonnez qu'en termes vous ne raisonnez
qu'en termes de photographie encore de
photographies en noir et blanc
argentique longues joutes oratoires avec
un ministre inflexible le ton du débat
sur les retraites vient d'être donné à
chaque question posée par les députés
socialistes compris la mienne
il a répondu par la caricature
l'invectivé voir la suite je crois pas
que ce soit une perte de sang froid
s'abat cct libérer pour faire croire
qu'il n'ya pas d'alternative au projet
du gouvernement
c'est un bon communicant parce qu'ils
communiquent pas c'est ça qui est assez
curieux vous savez les fed annonce
finalement tu les annonces et il y en a
trouvé qu'il était très bon communicant
parce qu'il désire rien sur la réforme
jusqu'à aujourd'hui une heure de baptême
du feu et nouveau départ au pas de
charge
le bras de fer politique et syndical
d'un ministre décidément très pressé
commence à peine
hier david douillet on voit des
collègues avoue dmp qui disent eux-mêmes
qu'il n'y a pas eu de communication
avant est ce que vous comprenez que les
syndicats l'opposition puisse dire
qu'ils n'ont pas été entendus et que on
les a mis devant un fait accompli semble
que cela fera pas le président public
wort
il ya eu il ya eu discussion
concertation et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
que là je vais répéter les mots d'eric
woerth
c'est pour ça qu'elle est responsable et
juste cette réforme pour le coup parce
que c'est seulement ce qu'on vous dit
dans votre circonscription par exemple
de la part c'est ce que j'explique dans
ce cahier d'ouvriers qui ont commencé à
travailler jeunes qui vont devoir
travailler plus longtemps de fab
c'est pas vrai parce que pour lui que
pour les carrières longues pour le coup
si vous avez bien là tous tous les gens
qui ont commencé un amant qui ont
commencé avant 18 ans pourront auront la
possibilité de partir à 60 ans des
jeunes au jour de l'ariège je pense à
ceux qui ont commencé à 13 ou 14 ans
journée dans ma circonscription âgées je
connais quelqu'un qui a commencé à 13
ans à être pâtissier a commencé son
métier il se faisait du souci quand je
lui ai expliqué qu'ils pourraient partir
tranquillement parce que le pauvre il a
donné il use et aujourd'hui ce normal
tranquillement comme tout le monde avant
60 ans
vous arrivez à les rassurer sur la
pénibilité parce qu'alors là dessus ça
va être un peu au cas par cas c'est le
médecin du travail qui va le décider
c'est un sujet qu'on c'est vrai que
c'est assez compliqué mais le fait
d'avoir le courage de prendre en compte
la pénalité parce que soient habilitées
la pénibilité je dis quoi la réalité
une invite à la pénibilité ça aurait pu
ce n'aurait pas été juste parce
qu'effectivement il ya des métiers où
c'est compliqué c'est très dur donc
d'avoir mis ce seuil à 20 % le taux
pénibilité et beaucoup d'anciens de
travail un cas par cas va va essayer de
la sortir du monde du travail ceux qui
ne peuvent plus travailler physiquement
et qui sont au bout parce qu'il ya aussi
pas mal d'exagération dans le sens
inverse c'est à dire pas de gens qui
sous prétexte qu'ils pensent être dans
un créneau de pénibilité qui essaie d'en
profiter un ou des abus dans
l'utilisation du système
vous pensez que alors que les sondages
disent pas que la majorité des français
sont hostiles à ce report à 62 ans ça va
passer c'est pas une réforme qui est
populaire c'est logique et tout le
travail qui a été fait et qui est à
faire encore c'est d'expliquer pourquoi
on est contraint on est obligé de le
faire
est ce que le choix et les simples enfin
je crois
est-ce qu'il fallait réagir en termes de
durée de temps à l'égal ou ou alors en
termes de à nouveau on impose le choix
est là quoi on avait des binaires en
s'entraînant avec les deux d'entre eux
depuis pas mal de taxes non au nous
parce que la taxation s'est pas fait sur
les retraités on n'a pas baissé les
retraites ça c'est très important et on
n'a pas augmenté les taux de prélèvement
pour les salariés ça c'est très abstrait
fonctionnaires c'est normal on les remet
à niveau
c'est juste il faut que la réforme est
juste on les remet au même niveau que
dans le privé c'est aussi simple que ça
si ç'avait été le cas si on avait
commencé à taper à choisir la facilité
c'est ce qu'est le ps préconise à
nouveau on descend le
le pouvoir d'achat à nouveau on grippe
la reprise et on est en ces temps de
crise s'était surtout parce qu'il
fallait faire encore une fois on a une
réponse intelligente démographique une
réponse démographique et de l'autre côté
il ya évidemment comme d'habitude la
taxe l'impôt la facilité on plombe les
échos ne suivrai eric woerth en la
défense de ce projet non non c'est la
philosophie de du bon sens je crois on
sait tous on passe à la journée de jeudi
et le var martyrisée par la tempête
la désolation qui se révèle dans toute
son ampleur pour les victimes des pluies
torrentielles dans le var les
intempéries qui ont particulièrement
frappé draguignan et ses alentours en 24
heures il a plu autant qu'en six mois et
dès à présent des questions sur les
défaillances dans la gestion du risque
qui commence à être posées elles sont
notamment par la mission sénatoriale qui
travaillait actuellement sur la tempête
xynthia
bérengère d'un glace 12 morts c'est ici
à draguignan que les inondations ont
fait le plus de victimes
pourtant dans cette commune du var les
crues on en a l'habitude
à la différence de la vendée un plan de
prévention des risques d'inondation
existe même depuis 2005 le problème
malgré les rappels réguliers de la
nature et des experts faute de volonté
politique
ce plan n'a eu aucun effet mardi quand
il ya un doute il faut on évacue on peut
pas laisser des populations se faire
piéger donc l'évacuation doit être une
réponse
surtout que là le système de vigilance
le système d alerte de météo france
avait bien fonctionné
cc on le voit bien aussi d'ailleurs dans
le var c'est ce qui se passe après
finalement qu'il fonctionne
on réussit à prévoir à peu près ont
réussi à alerter
mais l'information passe pas et on n'a
pas les bons réflexes car une fois
encore la catastrophe semblait
prévisible dans le rapport les experts
évoquent de graves problèmes en cas de
crue majeure
il rappelle que dans la zone inondable
de la naturby se trouve 50 bâtiments
commerciaux 150 habitations une maison
de retraite une urbanisation à outrance
que l'association france nature
environnement critique depuis longtemps
pour éviter la catastrophe n'a pas de
secret il faut arrêter d'artificialité
l'espace il faut arrêter
d'imperméabiliser décideront de surface
parce que une crue quand elle arrive sur
une zone totalement imperméable elle
accélère depuis la tempête xynthia une
quarantaine de victimes ont porté
plainte contre l'état les élus et les
collectivités locales
le rapport du sénat pointe également ses
nombreuses défaillances pour éviter de
nouvelles catastrophes à l'avenir il
faudra créer une vraie culture du risque
et cela rapidement
une vraie culture de risque un peu mais
aussi un élu local en ile de france ont
seulement députés mais conseiller
régional est-ce que c'est des questions
auxquelles on est suffisamment attentif
passé et je vais peut-être aller de soi
un sentier sur lequel peut-être personne
va parce que donc quasiment mon village
natal c'est arrivé quelques années ce
genre de choses et vous savez ce que
c'est ça c'est ce qu'il ya une plus
debout et qui a englouti une maison
faite tab et l'on comprenne pas si je
suis un peu public bellencombre et les
les
les vieux du village disait nous on
savait que dans cet endroit là il y
avait des problèmes parce que moi quand
j'étais gamin il y avait déjà eu ça pied
on a construit une maison ici voilà et
puis nous quand on dit les coups pour
dire aux agriculteurs aux jeunes arrêtés
d'arracher les respecter les les
couloirs d'écoulement etc ne les
bouchers pas ne l'avouerait pas les
chemins et cetera et cetera et cetera
choses qui sont faites aujourd'hui voilà
donc nacre et ma préconisations elles
seraient peut-être d'écouter les anciens
un petit peu qu'ils ont l'expérience et
ceux qui ont connu les territoires ddt
avant nos paies lui et ses avants
l'urbanisation pour l'arroser
l'allotissement leur poser
nous sommes en terrain où il y avait
d'écoulement le nombre j'en ai samassa
conscription le nombre de lotissements
fissurer parce qu'ils sont construits
sur des terrains avec des nappes
phréatiques quand il ya une sécheresse
qui s'appauvrissent des affaissements de
sun c'est monnaie courante ça arrive
tout le temps donc amender il va falloir
se rendre compte de ce qui était sans
faire un retour en arrière mais prendre
en compte ce qui est ce qui n'a pas été
fait avant pour le coup se poser la
question comme la fagne l'avalanche a
séduit même heure pourquoi on n'a pas
construit si c'est quelquefois parce
qu'il ya une bonne raison donc question
nos anciens pour le à léon ce jeudi
encore l'assemblée examine une
proposition de loi ump sur l'absentéisme
scolaire et la suppression possible des
allocations familiales
un système qui serait directement gérée
par l'éducation nationale et les
inspecteurs d'académie c'est une
proposition nous est cosigné david
douillet me semble-t-il avant d'en
parler on va voir les détails du
dispositif avec faustine delassus
suspendre les allocations familiales
c'est l'une des mesures phare de la
proposition de loi pour lutter contre
l'absentéisme scolaire
après quatre demi journées d'absence en
un mois le chef d'établissement signal
l'élève à l'inspecteur d'académie
ce dernier adresse un avertissement aux
parents la famille doit alors signé un
contrat de responsabilité parentale en
cas de nouvelle absence au cours de
l'année scolaire l'inspecteur d'académie
a l'obligation de saisir la caisse
d'allocations familiales les allocations
sont immédiatement suspendu les
versements seront débloqués
si l'élève est assidu pendant au moins
un mois ils seront alors rétroactif le
but de cette loi renforcer l'autorité
des parents et les accompagner pour
lutter contre l'absentéisme de leurs
enfants
en 2008 7 % des élèves étaient en
situation d'absentéisme ou de décrochage
par david douillet le texte a été un peu
adouci et lors du passage de votre
commission des affaires culturelles et
l'éducation mais est ce que vous pensez
pas que même que plutôt qu'aider les
parents on va les enfoncer un petit peu
plus non il ya un problème devrait
responsabiliser son époque franchement
il ya énormément de parents qui délègue
beaucoup trop l'éducation des enfants à
l'école donc et le son prix mais les
allocations familiales ordonnera de
l'autorité sur l'or sur leurs enfants
c'est une caisse qu'on leur en tire une
sonnette d'alarmé en leur disant vous
c'est à vous de faire aussi neuneu ne
rejetez pas votre votre mission sur un
club de sport sur l'école etc
non c'est à vous de faire il y a que
vous qui puissiez le problème est
d'ailleurs s'il pour les monnaies est
arrivé là c'est aussi de votre faute et
surtout trop de votre culpabilité s'est
pas risqué d'enfoncer davantage des
situations non je ne crois pas
franchement et d'ailleurs c'est pas les
culpabiliser parce que si les choses
rentrent dans l'ordre
très vite les hyènes rien rétroactivité
parler notre côté c'est vraiment une
mesure de prise de conscience
il ya je crois qu'il ya plusieurs choses
aussi un mais c'est une manière de
lutter contre l'absentéisme à l'école
l'absentéisme à l'école pour certains
c'est ne serait-ce que l'apprentissage
du français il français mais il parlait
un parce que malheureusement dans
certaines familles ne parle même pas
français
à la télé il ya il ya une télévision qui
ne parle pas français non plus il n'ya
que l'école qui peut les raccrocher à la
république donc six niveaux même famille
immigrée qui ne s'intégrait pas
suffisamment son mari mais en tout cas
pour ce type de femme il a en tout cas
c'est l'école est le seul moyen
d'arriver et de comprendre le pays dans
lequel ils sont et qu'ils sont même
français donc c'est quand même il faut
quand même faire quelque chose par
rapport à ça mais bien sûr ce n'est pas
la seule population
il ya autre chose c'est que je pense que
je me suis une réflexion par rapport aux
je pense qu'on devrait d'abord donner
beaucoup plus de pouvoir aux enseignants
aussi j'entends parler des sureffectifs
des munitions
personnels enseignants parce que le non
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur deux
etc
on a certes on a juste de 700 mille
élèves de moins qui à une certaine
époque et on a cinquante mille
enseignants plus juste un détail et que
maintenant à 25 ou 30 élèves
on se trouve en situation surchargé que
c'est pourquoi et ils ont raison de dire
ça parce que c'est plus difficile
aujourd'hui de tenir une 5 de 25 élèves
qui à 20 ans avec 40 r je crois qu'il
est tout simplement pour une des
disciplines et ces disciplines à ses
tenues là ce respect là vous l'avez ou
et grâce à qui aux profs oui certes mais
en leur donnant un peu plus de pouvoir
pour qu'ils puissent mieux faire leur
métier mais aussi aux parents à la
famille dès le départ à la famille dès
le départ et je crois qu'il l'aide à la
famille doit être conduit et initiés
mais dès le plus jeune âge de l'enfant
quand on a ciblé un type de population
vous parlez de familles immigrées c'est
pas forcément les familles immigrées
déjà visé c'est surtout les catégories
sociales basse on sait que dans les
catégories malheureusement social basse
ça va être plus particulièrement ce type
d'enfant là qui sont peu disposés à ne
pas aller à l'école ou à refuser tout ce
qui vient de l'état où la notion alors
on verra quelle suite sera donnée à
cette à ce projet à cette proposition
qui est actuellement en discussion on
termine la semaine avec la journée de
vendredi des ministres
accroché au tableau de chasse du canard
enchaîné
alain joyandet christian blanc rama yade
point commun de ces personnalités
politiques qu'elles sont toutes trois
épinglé cette semaine par le canard
enchaîné après christian estrosi et
fadela amara
des affaires qui ont les honneurs du
journal satirique est simple coïncidence
manoeuvre politique
reportage avec patrick armand scène le
canard enchaîné en fait-il trop de
l'appartement de fonction de christian
estrosi
prêté à sa fille à celui de fadela amara
mis gracieusement à la disposition de sa
famille sans oublier les cigares de
christian blanc
pas une semaine sans une révélation du
canard enchaîné sur un des membres du
gouvernement au siège du journal
satirique on réfute les accusations de
stratégie anti gouvernementales on parle
de hasard du calendrier et de dérives du
pouvoir on se dit pas la conférence de
rédaction tient à qui on va faire un
costard cette semaine ça se passe pas du
tout comme ça on entend tellement le
gouvernement et les ministres le premier
ministre y compris le président de la
république nous parler d'un état modeste
d'une république irréprochable c'est que
il ya un tel décalage avec la réalité
avec les gens qui quand même vivent un
peu sur la bête bon bah il ya des gens
que ça choque et le canard enchaîné et
reçoit comme ça d'aider des informations
sur des choses qui paraissent pas normal
des révélations qui font les choux gras
de canard et symbolise aussi un
changement d'époque
à l'ère de la communication politique la
transparence est à la mode mais
attention à l'effet boomerang c'est
qu'on a vu apparaître à partir de
du gouvernement actuel de l'élection
nicolas sarkozy
c'est une volonté de transparence qui a
été affichée qui a été revendiqué et du
coup ça aussi donner un blanc seing à la
presse pour s'occuper d'affaires qui
traditionnellement était de l'ordre du
privé alors lesquels et bien les
affaires liées aux os coeur les
relations sexuelles les partenaires mais
aussi l'argent les rémunérations et je
dirais que c'est un modèle qui se
rapproche peu à peu de du modèle de
presse de nos amis britanniques et
scandinaves
il faudrait donc s'attendre à une
multiplication des affaires à l'avenir
une bien mauvaise nouvelle pour un
gouvernement qui défend la rigueur
budgétaire alors dérives de la presse ou
dérives du pouvoir à un moment où vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure
les politiques doivent être exemplaires
oui non mais c'est l'argent public donc
voilà c'est tout c'est quelque part
l'argent des français il faut vraiment
veiller à être transparent au jeu
jaffiol
il sonne ici ben oui girona pas si on a
envie de se plier quelque chose avec son
argent personnel
c'est logique mais par exemple et à un
moment je vois là on vous avez vu venir
en porsche à l'assemblée nationale et de
la mienne
c'était la bonne vous l'avez toujours
non vous venez toujours en force
non non non est-ce qu'il faut être
comment oui parce que c'est un deal que
j'ai passé avec ma femme
c'était bien ça fait des années
gg ce type de véhicule puis toujours ce
c'est le véhicule de mes rêves quand
j'ai des gars à sa passion sinon
j'allais moyens de l'acheter je me suis
acheté j'ai sué sang et eau pour l'avoir
jeu là vous mais c'était ma voiture quoi
voilà elle m'a dit il va falloir que
c'est un danger ses voitures pour toi
parce que tu peux rouler très vite avec
ce type de voiture tout simplement
voilà donc comme s'éteindre ou alors tu
ne le fais que sur circuit
comme d'ailleurs sa main politique mais
comme moi je j'adore conduire bon voilà
donc c'était quand j'ai passé un deal
avec ma femme j'écoute plus + 50 il
adore chez moi ce n'est pas du tout
parce qu'en tant qu'élu de la république
on montre moins ces signes de richesse
non contents pour moi en tout cas parce
que moi j'ai eu une autre vie avant quoi
donc gg je le dis j'ai gagné des sous
avant parce que j'ai une vie j'ai créé
des entreprises j'étais athlète j'ai eu
la chance de gagner un gagner de
l'argent et je le dois qu'à moi je
compte démarrer le sport j'avais rien du
tout et mon engagement politique pour le
coup j'ai décidé de gagner beaucoup
moins d'argent parce que je voulais
c'est un vrai engagement alors évoqué
aussi et vos propres démêlés avec la
presse lors de votre campagne aux
législatives en septembre dernier eva
joly membre d'europe écologie et
ancienne juge d'instruction
vous accusez lors d'une conférence de
presse de posséder un compte au
liechtenstein
la phrase est diffusée sur france inter
vous porter plainte contre eva joly pour
diffamation et cette semaine c'est pour
ça qu'on en parle la journaliste a elle
aussi été mise en examen
sur initiative du juge d'instruction
pour complicité de diffamation
je vous propose d'écouter ça vous
intéresser la réaction du syndicat snj
de radio france
on est tout simplement non une affaire
de
2 l c'est une magistrate qui fait de
l'excès de zèle en voulant empêcher tout
bêtement les journalistes de faire leur
travail
aujourd'hui dans une campagne politique
on sait très bien que les attaques
fusent de part et d'autre les
journalistes sont là pour relayer cette
campagne sur le fond
certes sur la forme également on sait
qu'elle peut être violente david
douillet l'a appris à ses dépends
peut-être mais aujourd'hui le travail du
journaliste c'est de relayer ces propos
l'eau et c'est tout ce travail là qu'on
essaye d'empêcher aujourd'hui il est
vraiment un sentiment assez assez
frustrant et un sentiment
d'incompréhension quelque part alors la
journaliste n'a pas volé d'image elle
n'a pas volé deux sens était une
conférence de presse à ce qu'il est
normal à votre avis quelles qu'elles
soient mises en exigeant c'est pas moi
qui l'ait mise en examen attention c'est
la juge qui a décidé moi la seule
personne rien des vaches à lait je porte
plainte contre eva joly c'est la juge
qui décide d'elle-même ben moi je pars
du principe que quand on fait bien son
métier de journaliste il y en a qui font
très bien leur métier il ya un à dire là
dessus mais et j'en ai été victime déjà
pour sur d'autres rumeurs on a parlé de
porsche que je possédais mais on a dit
que c'était payé par les pièces jaunes
par exemple vous voyez ce genre de truc
quoi bon il se trouve que il faut
croiser ses informations à un moment
donné quand vous balancer quelques jours
alors si c'était vrai cette histoire de
comptes au liechtenstein
et si elle le dit ne pas de problème
elle a le droit de diffuser ce qui peut
être dit dans un meeting par une autre
personne sans problème
mais avant elle a la responsabilité de
des propos qui sont divulgués la de les
vérifier et d'être sûr que c'est vrai
c'est le travail du journalisme pour le
coup donc normal cette mise en examen
y compris du palais moi je vais
aucune action verts eva joly qui m'a dit
femme et parce qu'elle a dit une chose
faute et diffamantes pour moi en
campagne étoiles en plus pour me nuire
et nuire à mon intégrité
toutes les personnes qui essayent de
nuire à mon intégrité en disant
n'importe quoi tout tout et n'importe
quoi je les attaquerai systématiquement
je veux pas me laisser faire quand même
si on vous dit demain que vous êtes
pédophile vous allez réagir je suppose
moi c'est la même chose bon c'est normal
c'est le seul moyen que j'ai pour me
défendre et c'est compliqué de se
défendre sur quelque chose qui n'existe
pas notez le mais en tout cas le travail
des journalistes
quand les journalistes font bien leur
travail je le répète c'est de croiser
leurs forces et leurs informations et
d'être sûr et certain en tout cas
d'avoir plusieurs sources qui confirme
en tout cas un fait avant le diffuser
c'est de la responsabilité quand un
boulanger fait un peu ou vend un peu il
va pas vendre un peu périmées il est
responsable de ce qu'il produit c'est
logique c'est normal il faut avoir une
responsabilité
je suis pour la liberté de la presse
mais une presse qui fait son métier
voilà parce qu'il a fait en tout cas
qu'on suivra sur le plan judiciaire
puis la semaine se termine par le
lancement aussi du nouveau mouvement de
dominique de villepin une sorte d'appel
du 19 juin alors villepin qui doit
lancer ce mouvement
vous vous reconnaissez en lui la
continuité du gaullisme qui jusqu'à
preuve du contraire
je pense que dominique de villepin est
toujours de droite je croit même savoir
qu'il a sa carte à l'ump
donc pour moi c'est c'est quelqu'un qui
fait partie de la famille vous pourriez
être dans son mouvement
je sais pas ce qu'il ya dans ce nouveau
show est un des rares moments dans le
calcul est rien jean françois copé à son
mouvement aussi dominique wiel pas il ya
beaucoup de d'homme de droite de l'ump
en particulier qui créent des partis
politiques qui traitent des mouvements
de bourse vous êtes chiraquien j'allais
dire par affection sarkozyste par
ralliement en 2007 vous pourriez
d'angerville ronis chunhua je suis de
droite point à la ligne
voilà c'est tout je suis ni chacun et
shark ni sarkozyste ni villepiniste
nicoby je suis de droite et vous le
revendiquez et je le revendique fort et
j'ai décidé de m'inscrire dans cette
philosophie là voilà c'est tout et c'est
là même si la droite de jacques chirac
et de nicolas sarkozy pardon là mais la
droite de chirac et de sarkozy c'est la
même heure là tous des différences on
l'a tous des détails c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui fait la richesse de ce moment c'est
justement dans cette diversité de pensée
sur certains sujets qui en font sa
richesse et qui arrive au bout du compte
a proposé à proposer des choses qui ont
du bon sens qui ont de la tenue auprès
des français c'est mon sentiment
voilà et ben merci d'avoir partagé ces
trois quarts d'heure avec nous on se
retrouve même heure même lieu
votre rendez vous quotidien avec
l'information c'est du lundi au jeudi à
22 heures des débats des invités
politiques des vidéos insolites et
l'analyse de nos chroniqueurs ainsi que
le tour de l'information en images est à
22 heures pile sur public sénat
la croisette sélest'art à les paillettes
le glamour mais pas seulement le
festival de cannes est connu pour son
penchant pour les films engagés pour les
documentaires fine historique fiction la
plupart des longs métrages projetés ici
propose un regard sur la société qui les
entoure parfois les cinéastes comme
l'invention de la faire évoluer de
changer un peu les choses
cette 63e édition n'a pas été épargné
par les polémiques que ce soit au sujet
du film de rachid bouchareb hors la loi
sur la guerre d'algérie ou encore du
brûlot anti berlusconi de l'italienne
sabina guzzanti ce qui montre qu'ici à
cannes parfois le septième art dérange
alors quelles sont ses rapports avec le
politique par le regard qu'il porte sur
la société le signal peut-il influencer
ceux qui gouvernent par du monde s'est
délocalisé sur la côte d'azur à la
rencontre des cinéastes et des comédiens
du monde antique
à cannes les films décrivent l'état du
monde et parmi les thèmes stars cette
année la crise économique qui a ébranlé
la planète
au moins quatre films y était consacrée
de wall street l'argent ne dort jamais